il ne reste aucune trace sur ce terrain
des laurentides au bord d'un lac de ce
qui fut l'un des meilleurs studios de
son au monde le mythique studio de
morin-heights on est devenu avec georges
maertens studio la donne les deux
meilleurs studios au monde c'est un net
est absolument obsédé par la qualité du
sang il s'apprend des fous comme lui des
enthousiastes des gens qui exagèrent
dans un sens pour faire évoluer la
musique
sting david bowie et dj ce cat stevens
chicago
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les vedettes internationales des années
70 et 80 sont à peu près toutes passées
par ici
[Musique]
m
les états unis d'angleterre de france on
venait de partout chez andré pour rendre
hyper montée de l'île
de ré père et bonjour bonjour merci de
nous accueillir chez vous merci me
recevoir encore aujourd'hui vous êtes à
la recherche de la combinaison parfaite
pour retrouver le plus d'émotion dans la
musique c'est l'émotion voilà l'émotion
tout ce que ça prend pour la voir vous
savez l'émotion c'est clair musica nous
offre beaucoup plus que certains autres
domaines et c'est pour ça que moi
j'adore toujours je me replie besoin la
musique je fais signer avec ça
la musique c'est la musique a
certainement ça dépasse l'imagination
voilà c'est ma vie
à 86 ans dans des studios à montréal de
2 x hd avec son associé et ingénieur du
son run et la flamme ou dans son bureau
de sa maison de saint sauveur andré
perry travaille toujours à la recherche
du son parfait son obsession
recréer avec la technologie numérique la
qualité des vieux enregistrements
analogiques sur vinyle nos vieux disques
dont la qualité et la richesse n'ont
jamais été dépassé selon lui
vous avez déjà dit que le cd avait tué
le son vous encore aujourd'hui vous êtes
le numérique on fait avec la mais il
rien comme l'analogie que rien comme les
technologies plus traditionnelle pour un
son pur puis vous êtes là dans le super
hd donc vous n'arrêtez pas cette
recherche de l'absolu du son je parlais
trop technique mais l'analogue c'est une
scène way cc c'est comme ça c'est un
link comme ça ça enlève alors seydoux
savait y a pas de brisures de ne pas
quand je fais et le digital c'est les
bêtes ce débat s'est déclaré et les
baisses plus la résolution est et et
basso comme un cd plus entre les beats
il ya l'espace alors on est plus à
chaleur évidemment de numérique bien il
n'y a pas la deuxième harmonique lachal
à la ronde à l'achat peut pas enlever ça
ça c'est comme c'est qu'avec bien dans
les bras de quelqu'un versus belle femme
que tu regardes une tu regardes pilotis
la caresse et tu la tiens l'analogue
c'est ça mais on vient de voir que les
jeunes maintenant vient de découvrir
après quinze ans le faire bouffer
n'importe quoi laisser ce canal annonce
à des plaids analogue c'est curieux
c'est booth est maintenant l'analogue et
a dépassé les ventes de cd alors on
poser la question c'est comme ils
répondent le marché vient de parler
il a par exemple magnifier une chanson
de ginette reno enregistré en analogique
au début des années 60 je savais que
ginette une des choses absolument
exceptionnel dans sagen époque le 29 mai
deux ans en angleterre et à new york je
savais qu'il existait encore ces fioles
enregistrements de l'époque à wind est
là ou à l'anglais ouais à marley et moi
j'ai repris et s'agit ginette de moi
rhinois de princesses et j'ai remis
certains orchestration dessus 40 ans
cela
tombe à terre soit dit si tu sors ça
demain matin soit battu
[Musique]
non
vous vivez andré perry dans le futur
quand même tout avec l'âge je me suis
disons
spécialisés avec le temps qui me reste
est parfois à l'hiver l'analogique le
numérique qui va marier l'analogique
mais tout ça au bien-être de la musique
alors puis lâche tellement content avec
la venue des ddd de l'analogue qui
prends tu prends quand même ampleur
d'hommes se regardant ça peut-être avoir
avant j'avais peut-être le voir pour le
vrai tous ceux-là que finalement les
oreilles qui ont été soit il ya
longtemps ils sont plus fautifs sartoux
vrai bon
jeu puis voilà
[Musique]
c'est à 30 ans dans un sous-sol de
brossard en 68 son premier studio
qu'andré paris va enregistrer
l'extraordinaire lindbergh
monsieur
mais je descende
en soixante dix maintenant installé dans
une vieille église anglicane de la rue
amherst à montréal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et oui va aider jean pierre ferland à
produire un autre chef-d'oeuvre gens
mais dans ma tête il y avait autrefois
vous avez été derrière deux des plus
grands albums de l'histoire du québec
oui parce que vous êtes nostalgique ou
pour vous s'ils ne suis pas si ces faits
n'ont jamais jamais jamais je n'ai
jamais quand on l'a fait charlebois la
première journée de l'enregistrement de
charlebois écoute charge vers la maison
puisse gérer mes amis j'ai dit je
comprends pas ce que c'est a fait c'est
l'oeuf entier alors suit
sur québec erdre ans venant de miss
rennes ouest est hyper américaine jaune
c'est un disque qui se veut un peu plus
poétique un peu plus disons orchestrale
oui je savais que jaune c'est un grand
disque je ne sais pas comme comment
vraiment
d'apprendre la prochaine saison jean
pierre a été perdu et il l'a dit
d'ailleurs les entrevues c'est pas moi
qui le dit qui essayait rien à
comprendre jones est vraiment
d'expérimentation moi je t'ai pas tout à
fait prêt à ça puis je me pose est bien
des questions
laissez moi
et de là
or jaune permis va chercher aux états
unis des musiciens de jazz renommé comme
tenir les veines à la base qui
d'ailleurs collabore toujours avec jean
pierre ferland le métissage déjà à
l'époque vous vouliez vous teniez ce qui
est des musiciens américaine justement
qu'on avait pas de complexe à se faire
au québec il fallait qu'on se conforment
console wii côtoient d'autres musiciens
c'est à cette période on avait quand
même un complexe atteindrait évolution
tranquille on en soit fermé vers nous
mêmes moi c'est la terre qui
m'intéressait j'ai voyagé partout avec
les studios jal est partout partout à
chaque fois je voyais quelque chose
comme un petit québécois n'a encore
si je peux faire mieux que sobre que
j'allais voir à l'autre la jallère
batteries en france dès la reprise peut
faire mieux que sommes en
1969 la guerre du vietnam s'enlise le
mouvement pacifiste prend de l'ampleur
le conflit fera
1,7 million de morts dans la suite 17 42
de l'hôtel reine elizabeth à montréal le
1er juin 69 john lennon composent ce qui
deviendra une ode immortel à la paix
give peace a chance a été enregistré et
mixé par andré père joe tucci
[Applaudissements]
il
si cette chaise et si vous nerveux
gens à voter non à première vue mais
coûte c'est une histoire qui est
fantastique parce que maintenant c'est
ici c'était pas utilisable d'une part
parce que j'avais ce qu'on appelle
destins
parallèles de la fontasse cet accord et
puis enfin beaucoup de monde ça frappait
seulement parfois de cendrieux ai cru qu
il y avait un lien avec sa passion
l'époque et en avec le chanteur info 1
avec chanter pourtant tout ce qu'on
avait quelques joies des tambourinaires
après les friches c'est le bordel il m'a
regardé à prix
doux et la ja appli charlebois ga klimov
g à petit ma gang j'appuie les gens avec
qui je travaillais à l'époque puis je
leur ai dit lui aussi jouve est vite la
gombe enfin on fait débat cas pour une
jeune les mêmes et on dit il pas bien
haut quoi puis le flamand ils ont
réalisé que oui festival jean launay
nutella et on lâche les écouter je sais
ce qui va entendre alors j'essaie plus
et en conséquence pas d'harmonie tout ça
et après ça ils sont partis et là j'ai
été chercher mon corps de vidange quand
tu en caoutchouc parce qu'ils voulaient
donner un espèce de son pistolet de
l'époque un espèce de troy alors quand
on les écoute d'être cammas à m'attendre
je me retourne à l'hôtel nous fait
sortir tout le monde je suis écouté j'ai
fait est prévu une version javel
original vous retourner
hamada tard avec souley et les
quotidiens s entre labos
[Applaudissements]
des magasins crédit qu'on n'avait jamais
vu dans l'histoire du verre à
l'adresse le nom du studio après bon ce
sera ensuite les années d'or du studio
de marinette qu'est ce que vous aviez
offrir deux spéciales parce que des
arbres au pyla qui en a partout sur la
planète qu'est-ce qui a fait que c'est
devenu une destination internationale
premièrement ces tâches et adrien parce
que le fait que la grande majorité des
studios était propriété de major
columbia et compagnie et c'était peut
gérer comme des boîtes un peu plus
froide et alors moi ils n'échangeraient
qui était un de leurs essais j'étais
comme eux j'étais un musicien j'étais
j'ai été ingénieur j'étais réalisateur
j'étais un gastronome j'étais un bon
vivant les longs météo québec aussi où
on avait notre différence car cela était
le premier à venir on va venir vous
sentir un peu joué pour tous au jour est
resté du mois d'avril a fait quatre
disques moi je voulais prendre
l'étranger peut l'amener ici c'est un
peu ce qui était arrivé alors tu ne vis
pas de ça à moi de faire des êtres c'est
bien beau de grand chef de
bel hôtel pour 8 août tous sont riches
en plein dans le réveillon alors c'est
pas ça c'était parce qu'on faisait à
billets est aussi celle ont livré la
marchandise
et c'est comme ça on est devenu avec
georges martin des
studios landel les deux meilleurs suivis
au monde un certain moment et nous on ne
pensait jamais à ça on continue et on
continue cette annexe d'alex dans la
roue qui roulent dans la création qui se
faisaient les changes et que tenaient
les bee gees fallait trouver un son on
n'avait pas de sens nous tous les
studios avait un son particulier les
bêtises qui ont fait ça les nike free
veut bien dire au canda fini voiceover
on sent remix est à miami je suis ok
j'ai pris ma gagne qui durant la nuit on
a tourné
trois ferrari 1 puis la ferrari est
devenu un de l'enceinte a le lendemain
sont eux aussi jouent système wimax
illégale d'intérêts
[Musique]
on recherche une chose
c'est sa c5 magique et on peut passer
des oeuvres déjà des heures de travail à
chercher ce cinq minutes et à ce
sentiment ce feeling andré perret cette
période là où les gens venaient à mourir
à faire des albums pouvait passer des
semaines chez vous
comme vous dites il y avait de l'argent
il y avait est-ce que c'est révoltant ya
les exceptions le polish pas encore
faire saliou tout peut encore faire ça
mais sinon il n'y a plus assez d'argent
à cette industrie là pour faire ce genre
d'exercice lokua parce qu'on ne put un
métier les gens sont peu pays c'est
l'âge n'ont pas l'âge d'or du studio là
elle navigue à travers les grands stars
et tout ça ben écoute les gens étaient
pays et c'était dominé aussi par des
gens de musique saisir les compagnies de
disque n'était pas gérée par des par des
avocats ou des fonctionnaires sont
s'arrête au québec c'est affreux et
c'est très très difficile mais ça papa
de younes nada salue le night fever qui
avait vendu 36 millions de disques et
ont découvert en
piraterie
déjà à cette époque là on serait que le
40 une quarantaine d'années la néra
vendu plus que ce qu'elle va avoir du
beau le vrai hélas la musique de rue
gratuit place par mois d'action musique
que tu veux puis les artistes ils
reçoivent à peu près rayé alors c'est
très difficile pour le métier vraiment
ça c'est le côté qui m'adresser
normalement il n'y a rien à faire et
l'ex à ces dominé par maintenant trop
gros majeurs qui ont acheté toutes les
indépendants les indépendants sont tous
réveillés à l'époque que moi et me suis
réveillé envoyait l'envoyer saxe arriver
là et puis finalement comment on s'en
sort je ne sais pas peut-être un peu
plus de respect un peu plus un peu plus
d'argent aussi un peu plus de
je n'ai pas de solution c'est la
première fois que j'ai pris sur un coin
de rue la puis je manque de jeu manque
de
carburant mais ça vous inquiète
ça vous inquiète les analystes
ça vous attriste ça m'attriste ouais ça
m'inquiète pas ça m'attriste ça
m'attriste parce que la musique c'est
l'art la plus touchante la plus profonde
la chose qu'il ya plus stimulantes et
quand je la vois mal traités c'est comme
mettre été
maltraité un peu la chose qui lui met le
pichet finalement vous avez la passion
encore du sceau de l'émotion
vous travaillez encore dans le son vous
avez été en coulisses lors de projets
fort important pour l'histoire de la
musique du québec c'est quoi votre
moteur qu'est ce qui vous fait courir le
moteur c'est la passion si on peut faire
un parallèle simple c'est un escalier
hockey et l'escalier et quand j'ai bu
décidé d'aller vers l'international
simplement avec le studio c'est que sais
je me regardais puis je trouvais que
j'étais monté au bout de l'escalier ici
pendant sens péjoratif
puis d'un autre côté j'avais besoin
j'avais soif d'aller plus loin
[Musique]
de son église au il a en trop
d'enregistrer la magnifique chanson un
peu plus haut un peu plus loin écrite
par ferland jusqu'à aujourd'hui avec ces
technologies numériques avancés en
passant par le studio des laurentides
andré perry a toujours été à l'affût
finalement d'une seule chose le talent
faire jaillir une oeuvre être un
facilitateur
d'émotion et tant d'années après tant de
musées qu'après la capacité
d'émerveillement de ce passionné demeure
intacte
ceux-là trop grand et là ça va pleurer
ces garanties ce plan prend alors ses
projets
[Musique]
ah si
[Applaudissements]
vous avez comme gagner votre période et
paris le petit gars de verdun que pro
fini sa sixième année il est allé loin
moins 10 par an vous dites vous à
m'arrête pas à ça je m'arrête pas si
c'est par andré perret qui est toujours
le stade ventes us et histoire c'est que
je m'entoure des meilleurs que moi que
ce soit comme j'ai dit les messieurs où
d'autres et dans le code du hd
confirmant le moment c'est mon associé
qui est un génie de la technique aussi
alors rené la flamme un québécois aussi
où je peux oublier qu'à el hocine
absolument pas ce que je n'aurais jamais
eu la carrière que j'ai sans elle c'est
clair je sais que ça sonne un peu fleur
bleue mais c'est pas ça du tout
cinquante sept ans ensemble c'est
m'amuse c'est une femme qui qui
absolument qui a toutes les qualités
dont je n'ai pas et vous allez demander
à n'importe qui dans le métier ce
qu'elle y à elle et puis vous dire c'est
une femme absolument remarquable ça
c'est très frais vrai aussi j'étais
gratter là pas mal au c
c'est votre équilibre c'est mon
équilibre donc pas de retraite à court
terme non impossible l'impasse et coco
coureurs en a ailleurs
mais je pense pas tant que ça c'est le
chiffre qui est pas beau
maudit chiffre qui 32 dans ces sacs et
les curieux
andré père de mercy me l'a appris
[Musique]